GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
FOX NEWS PRIME TIME, I'M WILL
CAIN.
WE START ON CAPITOL HILL WHERE
MERRICK GARLAND WAS ON THE HOT
SEAT, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WAS
GRILLED OVER HIS DOJ MEMO
TARGETING CONCERNED PARENTS AT
SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS, IT ALL
STARTED LAST MONTH WHEN THE
NATIONAL SCHOOL BOARD
ASSOCIATION SENT A LETTER TO
JOE BIDEN DEMANDING ACTION OVER
WHAT THEY CALL VIOLENCE AND
INTIMIDATION AT BOARD MEETINGS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY BUT LISTEN TO
THIS.
NEW REPORTING REVEALS THAT THE
NS B.A. HAD "COLLABORATED WITH
THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE BEFORE
SENDING A CONTROVERSIAL LETTER
CALLING ON THE FBI TO
INVESTIGATE PARENTS AS POTENTIAL
DOMESTIC TERRORIST.
"WAS THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
COLLUDING, WITH THE NATIONAL
SCHOOL BOARD ADMINISTRATION,
WITH THE WHITE HOUSE WEAPONIZE
THE DOJ TO LABEL PARENTS ALL
ACROSS THIS GREAT NATION AS
DOMESTIC TERRORISTS?
THE ANSWERS TO THOSE QUESTIONS
SEEM TO BE UNEQUIVOCALLY YES.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND THEN
QUICKLY FOLLOWED THE NS B.A.'S
LEAD A MEMO SAYING THEY WOULD
IDENTIFY AND PROSECUTE THESE
DOMESTIC THREATS.
BUT HOW DID THE DOJ REACH THAT
CONCLUSION?
DID THEY DO SOME TYPE OF
IN-DEPTH RESEARCH?
DID THEY CONDUCT A NATIONWIDE
INVESTIGATION, DID THEY HAVE
SPECIFIC THREATS?
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN WANTED TO
FIND OUT.
>> WANTED YOU FIRST REVIEW THE
DATA SHOWING THIS SO-CALLED
DISTURBING UPTICK?
>> I READ THE LETTER AND WE HAVE
BEEN SEEING OVER TIME --
>> I DIDN'T ASK YOU, YOU READ
THE LETTER, THAT IS YOUR SOURCE?
>> LET ME BE CLEAR, THIS IS NOT
A PROSECUTION --
>> SOME STUDY, SOME
INVESTIGATION SOMEONE DID THAT
SAID THERE WAS A DISTURBING
UPTICK OR YOU TAKE THE WORD OF
THE NATIONAL SCHOOL BOARD
ASSOCIATION?
>> Will: NOTHING MORE THAN A
LETTER, GARLAND WOULDN'T GIVE A
STRAIGHT ANSWER BUT HE WOULD
GIVE NOTHING MORE THAN A LETTER
AS THE PREDICATE TO THIS
INVESTIGATION.
CONGRESSMAN JORDAN WAS CUT OFF
BEFORE HE COULD PRESS ANY MORE.
IT'S OBVIOUS THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE WAS FOLLOWING THE NS
BAS LEAD AND THE DOJ WAS
FOLLOWING THE WHITE HOUSE'S
LEAD.
THAT IS NOT THE ONLY CONCERN
CONGRESS HAD WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, LOUISIANA
CONGRESSMAN MIKE JOHNSON TOOK
THE ATTACK FOR HIS FAMILY'S
BUSINESS TIES FOR CRITICAL RACE
THEORY.
>> YOUR ACTIONS MAY HAVE BEEN
MOTIVATED BY YOUR FAMILY'S
FINANCIAL STAKE IN THIS ISSUE,
PUBLISHER REPORTS SHOW YOUR
SON-IN-LAW OFF COFOUNDED A
COMPANY CALLED PANORAMA
EDUCATION, WE NOW KNOW THAT
COMPANY PUBLISHES AND SELLS
CRITICAL RACE THEORY AND ITS
SO-CALLED ANTIRACISM MATERIALS
TO SCHOOLS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
DID YOU SEEK ETHICS COUNSEL
BEFORE YOU ISSUED A LETTER THAT
DIRECTLY RELATES TO THE
FINANCIAL INTERESTS OF YOUR
FAMILY, YES OR NO?
>> THIS MEMORANDUM DOES NOT
RELATE TO THE FINANCIAL
INTERESTS OF ANY ONE.
>> I TAKE THAT AS A NO.
>> Will: TO BE CLEAR, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S SON-IN-LAW
SELLS CRITICAL RACE THEORY
PROCESSES AND PRODUCTS TO MORE
THAN 23,000 SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
SCHOOLS THIS COUNTRY.
IF THAT'S NOT BEING COMPROMISED,
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IS.
THE WHITE HOUSE, THE DOJ ALL
COMPROMISED IN THEIR CONNECTIONS
WITH BOTH THE NATIONAL SCHOOL
BOARD ASSOCIATION AND WITH
CRITICAL RACE THEORY.
AND YET THEY CONTINUE TO PUSH
ON, TARGETING CONCERNED PARENTS.
WHY IS THIS SO IMPORTANT?
HERE'S ONE REAL-WORLD
CONSEQUENCE TO WHAT IS INSIDE
THAT LETTER.
ONE OF THE PEOPLE THE NS B.A.
TARGETED AS A DOMESTIC TERRORIST
IS A FATHER FROM LOUDOUN COUNTY,
VIRGINIA, WHY?
HE SHOWED UP TO PROTEST.
AT A SCHOOL BOARD MEETING, THAT
PARENTS NAME IS SCOTT SMITH AND
AS YOU CAN SEE HERE, HE WAS
PINNED DOWN BY POLICE AND THE
REST OF THE SCHOOL BOARD MEETING
IN JUNE.
SMITH WANTED ACCOUNTABILITY FROM
THE SCHOOL BOARD AFTER THEIR
TRANSGENDER POLICIES LED TO HIS
TEENAGE DAUGHTER BEING ALLEGEDLY
RAPED IN THE SCHOOL BATHROOM BY
A MAN IN THE SKIRT.
OBVIOUSLY A HARROWING EXPERIENCE
NO PARENT SHOULD HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THAT EVERY PARENT WOULD
WANT TO FIND ACCOUNTABILITY ON.
INSTEAD OF DOING ANYTHING TO
HELP SMITH TO ALLAY HIS
CONCERNS, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS LOOKING TO
VILIFY HIM IN THE HUNDREDS OF
OTHER PARENTS AS DOMESTIC
TERRORISTS.
CONGRESSMAN CHIP ROY OF TEXAS
WOULD NOT LET GARLAND GET AWAY
WITH THIS.
>> THE GIRL WHO HAD DEFENDED
RAPED, IN A BATHROOM IN
HIGH SCHOOL BY A DUDE WEARING A
SKIRT, THAT FATHER REACTED.
HE BECAME THE POSTER BOY FOR THE
NEW DOMESTIC TERRORISM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS CONCOCTED
ANYONE WHO GETS IN THE WAY.
DO YOU BELIEVE A FATHER
ATTENDING A MEETING EXERCISING
HIS FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS AND
GETTING ANGRY ABOUT WHATEVER
LIES ARE BEING TOLD ABOUT HIS
DAUGHTER BEING A RAPED IN THE
SCHOOL HE SENT HER TO BE
EDUCATED AND, THIS IS DOMESTIC
TERRORISM, YES OR NO?
>> I DON'T THINK PARENTS GETTING
ANGRY AT SCHOOL BOARDS FOR
WHATEVER REASON CONSTITUTES
DOMESTIC TERRORISM.
>> Will: WHY DID YOU SEND THAT
LETTER, WHY DID YOU ISSUE THAT
MEMO?
WHY TARGET PARENTS ACROSS THIS